[Música]
en 2018 jean-philippe zamba le guen se
lanzó a una aventura para salvar esta
vieja estación ferroviaria que iba a ser
destruida
[Música]
ella amigos pronto llegará un tren
atención al silbato
este vendedor retirado compró el
edificio por 70 mil euros con la idea de
volver a darle vida
para hacerlo abre de manera voluntaria
sus puertas a los viajeros que pasan por
la situación
cuando viaja hoy bien para ir abre su ir
hoy no es tan sencillo llegar a esta
noche debe tomar el autobús en pontivy
hacia el mediodía llegará a vanessa a
las 1315 usted trabaja para la
ferroviaria estatal no no yo soy un
fanático de los trenes le doy
información a las personas que entran a
la estación hasta luego millas gracias
hasta luego en su estación jean-philippe
no sólo reciben cajeros perdidos sino
también antiguos empleados ferroviarios
nostálgicos curiosos por ver qué ocurrió
con sus puestos de trabajo
recién active todo
vamos a mi oficina vengan vengan
[Música]
buenos dias pontivy dígame si se lo pasó
a los y la estación de vance
yo era gente suplente en band así que
venía de vez en cuando venía para
reemplazar al jefe de la estación y esta
es la primera vez que vuelve si es la
primera vez no pensé que fuera volver a
visitar así la estación llevado por el
entusiasmo de jean-philippe el antiguo
empleado viaja al pasado en esta oficina
tengo la impresión de haber sido yo el
que llenó esto tómalo tómalo puedes
llevarte no guárdalo es un recuerdo pero
tengo muchos contigo y tómalo en una
época había unas 30 personas trabajando
aquí y cuando yo llegué todos los demás
puestos habían sido suprimidos pero en
las oficinas parecía como si las
personas hubiesen terminado su turno a
las 10 de la noche y hubieran dejado
todo lo que era gracioso parecía una
especie de museo
jean-philippe es por este tipo de
momentos que compró esta estación sí
claro nos tuteamos no nos conocemos pero
nos tuteamos porque somos antiguos
empleados ferroviarios así es gracias
por haber venido regresa cuando quieras
aquí estás en tu casa un encuentro
acorde al proyecto del gran finito darle
un nuevo soplo de vida a la estación
deportiva
pero el edificio necesita una gran
restauración así que jean philippe
acudió a una arquitecta
debes siempre mirar a la derecha y a la
izquierda y circulación
para renovar esta estación que se
remonta al siglo 19 será necesario
reconstruir el exterior de manera
idéntica la fachada en ladrillo y piedra
toba y también los postigos y las
ventanas
es un edificio que hace parte de los
edificios destacados así que es verdad
que no podemos hacer todo lo que
queramos está muy bien para mí está muy
bien porque yo quiero renovar el
edificio tal como era antes la estación
de pont tv fue construida en
1864 se escribió en un proyecto de
modernización iniciado unos años antes
por napoleón primero para convertir esta
ciudad en uno de los grandes cruces de
bretaña
[Música]
en la nueva ciudad muchas calles
recuerden las campañas imperiales más
gloriosas la estación aún conserva
recuerdo y el tiempo en el que pontivy
llevaba el prestigioso nombre de
napoleón vil ciudad de napoleón
o sea sandrine tengo una idea y si
conservamos este sistema en el nuevo
apartamento no no es una buena idea en
la primera planta se encuentra en los
antiguos alojamientos de los
funcionarios ferroviarios
que se ha deteriorado mucho vista estafa
llevas tan bonitas si es magnífico si
son fallidas napoleónicas originales
además de sus ahorros y préstamos en
phillip cuenta con el alquiler de estos
cuatro apartamentos renovados para
financiar los 800 mil euros necesarios
para el proyecto la parte de abajo se
quedará así porque estará abierta al
público y quiero que conserve el
espíritu de adaptación pero arriba hay
que hacer alojamientos modernos hay que
hacer algo lindo
mientras logras llevar a cabo la
renovación de su estación de libia con
frecuencia aludec
a 30 km de ponti vi a una asociación de
aficionados que restauran viejas
locomotoras
[Música]
en el vagón restaurante el ambiente es
relajado johann philipp cuenta con esta
asociación para crear un pequeño tren
turístico que se detenga en su estación
perdón
la línea
y
cuento con ustedes compañeros para que
haya trenes con viajeros ya lo dije
cuento con ustedes amigos era un sueño
inesperado lo confieso y ahora
francamente creo en él creo en él
el proyecto aún está pendiente de contar
con autorizaciones pero va por buen
camino la asociación puso en marcha este
automotor de 1952 que solía detenerse en
la estación de pont tv hasta el cierre
de la línea en 1987 el automotor
turístico tan esperado por jean philippe
muy pronto podría regresar a su antigua
estación
[Música]
y